first I need to say I love Star Wars
when the new trailer came out it
immediately caused a ripple in my force
it had everything Star Wars fans were
looking for x-wings TIE fighters the
Millennium Falcon but it also had a
curious shot of a lightsaber with two
smaller lightsaber cross beams coming
out of the hill many fans immediately
derided this as silly other saw it as a
fun twist on a fan standard but I saw
does something completely different in
America today when everyone's all PC and
stuff there is no mistaking this as
another sign of the creeping nanny-state
here Mia as everyone knows the only
thing that can stop a lightsaber is
another lightsaber and so the tiny
lightsaber beams are being explained as
a safety precaution to protect your hand
is this really what it's come to Star
Wars used to be the Wild West it was
awesome sure sometimes bad things happen
to good people but that's what made it
great Star Wars had a careless disregard
for employee safety like a mile-high
tractor being with no safety rims and
there certainly weren't any safety rails
on Cloud City you're in the clouds it's
clearly windy and you're 37,000 miles in
the air what about the superlaser on the
Death Star that can literally destroy a
planet and the guys operating it are so
close that the radiation alone should
have killed them and still no safety
railing what about the stormtroopers
their bulky armoured are required to
wear if you please me useless it doesn't
protect them from blasters or tiny bears
now that is the Star Wars I remember and
all of a sudden were adding extra safety
precautions to protect a Sith Lord
what's next your regulations on
workplace harassment give me a break
once again Hollywood liberals with their
limousine airplanes and quinoa wine are
messing with my galaxy far far away
although it does look pretty rad